12 millions trois cent seize mille sept
cents élèves vous voyez que nous aimons
les chiffres précis à 12 millions trois
cent seize mille sept cents élèves
entreront donc en classe vendredi
prochain que ce soit dans des écoles
publiques ou privées ils seront quarante
sept mille de plus que l'an dernier ce
qui ma foi est encourageant si l'on sait
que de 78 à 82
on avait enregistré une baisse des
effectifs et cela pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la scolarité
c'est donc dans ce contexte que monsieur
chevènement a tenu conférence de presse
la première
bruno le dreff première rentrée et
premier examen pour le nouveau ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui faisait
face ce matin à la presse spécialisée
une semaine après ses propositions à
l'enseignement privé mais trois jours
seulement avant la rentrée jean pierre
chevènement a voulu consacrer cette
conférence de presse aux élèves et aux
enseignants
mais c'est presque un ancien ministre de
l'industrie qu'il a insisté sur
l'importance de la formation des jeunes
dans le développement économique du pays
comment ne pas être sensible au fait que
les pays qui remporte deux grands succès
technologiques commerciaux économiques
sont précisément ceux qui ont su
investir dans l'éducation
au delà de l'âge de 16 ans qui est en
france l'âge légal de la scolarisation à
17 ans 18 ans 19 ans les jeunes de pays
comme l'allemagne les états unis le
japon sont scolarisés en plus grand
nombre que les nôtres l'école sera donc
pour le gouvernement une des priorités
des années à venir avec b de cette année
un budget en augmentation sensible + 8,7
fois sans accompagnée de la création de
2300 emplois en maternelle 14 100 places
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes pour
les collèges l'expérience de rénovation
va se poursuivre seize mille nouvelles
places sont offertes aux élèves de
l'enseignement technique et puis
l'informatique
elle arrive à l'école à grands pas 35000
micro ordinateurs dans les classes pour
cette année on aurait presque envie
retourner à l'école